and a man who knows what it's like to
call those big events is joining us here
in studio one of my good friends on
planet earth thrilled I can call him
that after now it's finished 14th season
is the voice of just Sunday Night
Football alone one of the all-time
greats Al Michaels good to see you sir
good to see you welcome home thank you
sir appreciate you're back from Miami
I'm here from Brentwood pretty good I
come in here and then you lose power the
whole story goes down that's right I
show up and there's an earthquake or a
power hitter I mean the lights went out
in El Segundo we're back on on TV radio
and and all that good stuff what'd you
think of the game last night no what'd
you think the game about I thought it
would be higher scoring early on I knew
it would be a close competitive game you
know I felt going in that that that pass
rush of the 49ers could make the
difference and I think it did early on
toward the end of course we all know
what happened my home's got hot
the 49ers couldn't get to him you know
what's interesting I've been listening
of course over the past you know 16
hours or whatever it's been to what
everybody's talking about and clearly
the third and 15 is gigantic
the pass to Tyree kill them Holmes come
back etc etc some of the 49er strategic
decisions but you know when I kept
thinking back to what's that mahomes in
October in Denver the quarterback sneak
people forget about that but it looks
like Kansas City season is over no he's
on the bottom of the pile and you know
it's funny because we had them I got a
review of my notes from the the game we
did with them in Chicago and I talked to
my home's I said tell me what you felt
like you know for the next 10 seconds or
so he said I knew I knew I had a first
down I felt something hit my leg could
not move my leg didn't know what was
wrong knee cap was on the side of my leg
so all the worst thoughts can't move
season's over doctor came out popped my
knee back in two steps I felt fine I
thought it was going back on the game
doc said I'm good but you're not going
back in the game so you think about that
and how close their season came to
ending and you know we should get a
little shout out right now is Matt Moore
oh yeah because Matt Moore who had not
played last year and I think was
coaching his kids in high school
football
or junior football some sort of a kids
football out here in Southern California
he comes in and here he got him to come
back he finished that game in Denver
they won the game right the next week we
had him against Green Bay that was our
Sunday night that was gonna be the
number one game we had all year my homes
against Rodgers turned out to be more
against Rodgers but Moore played very
well at night then he won the next game
I think against Minnesota
they had a bye week mahomes came back
but you know that win that they had
against Minnesota was so critical and
the victory that he was able to sustain
against the Denver Broncos put them in a
position to get that bye no doubt and so
you keep forgetting about all the little
things that happen to the beginning of
the year and then mahomes comes back and
it's it's kind of it's an amazing thing
I mean the doctor comes out pops your
kneecap back in I mean just he was he
was telling us a story and where we know
we're cringing because it sounds so
insidious in a way and yet here he was
at the end of the year and you don't
even think about that anymore because
he's playing I mean he played at the
fourth quarter obviously at the highest
level yeah I mean I honestly thought the
Saints were gonna make the Super Bowl
this year and one of the reasons why if
they if they had would have been
Bridgewater going 500 more almost went
through you know with mahomes out after
that knee being on its side and and he's
now got a Super Bowl ring he was
coaching high school he was at Kyler
Murray's pro day if I'm not mistaken
right he was I mean just just observing
and and man I love stories like this I
love love love stories like this people
who are persevering and more we all know
I'm obviously about Damian Williams
being back in Miami that's where Moore
was a quarterback when Tannehill went
down and he played in a playoff game
against the Steelers and got blown up I
mean I just love stories like that oh
yeah there's the best I mean especially
you know a backup quarterback coming in
and you know and Moore said to us when
we did that Green Bay game that it was
all about Andy Reid Andy called him he
wanted to go and play for Andy
and you know so we all know that you
know so the football community loves and
Erie my gosh there's a lot to love there
to Amin when he's a wonderful man he's
coached for 21 straight years you and I
both know he said heartache on the field
and off the field he's always been the
same man the funny thing about him is
beaten we covered him for a ton of years
in Philadelphia and I thought of only
coaches that I saw who lasted a long
time he was the one guy I thought really
needed a year off and I even said it on
the air at one point and and then I
talked to him you know when he took the
Kansas City job and I said did you think
about taking your obvi said absolutely
not and Kansas City got you know right
on the phone after he was let go by the
Philadelphia Eagles he's a coach he's a
wonderful man I'm so happy for him and
and for the family and you know so Tammy
was on the understand yesterday along
with him and she's been his rock through
all of these these years and it's it's
great it's just so good because you know
I remember when I did the Super Bowl
with John Madden back in O 5 when
Pittsburgh met Seattle in Detroit yep
and I think John at the top of the show
said about Bill Cowher he said this is
you this is the yeah but Bill Cowher is
a great coach but so Andy finally got
rid of the Year button there's no
question that someday he will be making
a speech in Canton I agree with you Al
Michaels here and the Rich Eisen show
and another reason why cuz we're talking
about it with mooch who goes way back
with Andy Reid to the Green Bay days is
he's got two hundred and twenty some odd
career wins and he's got a quarterback
who just became the first human to win a
league MVP and a Super Bowl and not yet
be 25
I mean Andy's a young man in his early
60s he wants to keep coaching ten more
years you could just do the math you
know I mean with my home staying healthy
knock on wood I mean you could be
talking about and another hundred wins
for him regular season in who knows
playoffs obviously we have to see it but
you could envision it right now no you
said there's no question I mean I think
yes I mean they they could go rolling
down the
this next decade and and when it's three
or four times at this particular point
but then again you know look you never
know when a kneecap gets dislocated and
they can't put it back in see you don't
know what's going to happen I mean the
injuries of course are so so gigantic
you look at Tom Brady's career he only
had that one injury that meat you know
the the the knee on opening day back in
2008 they still want 11 games I think
that year but mathematics took them out
of the playoffs so you know that's the
dynasty we think about we think about
the 49ers back in in the 80s and 90s he
had Montana and he had young and he had
Walsh and you know she firt inherited
that team and and won a couple of Super
Bowls as well yeah I mean when you look
at Kansas City and the way that
organization is structured I mean
they're very very solid the hunt family
we know about from obviously from the
beginning of time lamar founding the
franchise and the American Football
League Clarke taking over right now
Brett Fisher I know you'll have on the
show later it's done a great job
internally they're set up the right way
they really got a great they've got a
great thing going right now and they've
got a lot of stars and this is a team
that it last year I mean they were able
to sustain the loss of a guy who led the
league in rushing the year before people
forget about that too
Kareem hunt goes out so and then we
Tyreke Hill had his issues and all of
that so it wasn't all you know candy and
candies and flowers there but they were
able to they were able to get through
everything and that I think is really
what Andy Reid is is great at he's
really good at assessing every situation
getting it right in a way they go now
Michaels here on the Rich Eisen show it
does help though to have a kid who can
be as dynamic as mahomes is who can as
you just read off your your phone there
tell you that story about his kneecap
being on the side of his leg and three
weeks later be back in under center and
Andy read that by week was two weeks
after they put him back in the game
after a game in Mexico where everything
looked great a year ago we all know
there was some issue with the turf and
that's why everyone's saying I'll just
keep him out for two weeks but he is
just so unconventional
good that it overcomes what you normally
would say conventionally would be wise
to do
where does mahomes rank for you and
quarterbacks that you have seen suit up
al over the years he's he's only been a
starter for two years here two years
he's won an MVP award I mean right now
and you know when you want to put the
numbers to it in the analytics and all
the rest and I don't think anybody's
really had the beginning of a career
like he has I think the only one you
could say is Marino right right RINO
made it so young and he did have a coach
that we knew had Hall of Fame
credentials and we thought he's gonna
keep going and never know made it back
no but that the one Super Bowl right
second year lost to Montana that's the
only thing you could think of that might
be maybe in terms of the beginning of a
career I don't know yeah and the thing
about him and everybody knows this now -
because you watch the way he handles
himself you watch the interviews that he
does that's him that's such that's like
he's a great he's a great young kid he
really is young kid young young guy gets
it I know a lot has been said about the
fact that he kind of grew up in a
professional sports Clubhouse that Pat
was a ten year nine or ten year pitcher
in the major leagues mainly with
Minnesota but but Patrick was used to
showing up in in those types of
environments
he gets it though he so really he's a
he's such a likable guy that you know
you root for him you root for an Andy
Reid and you know when I looked at that
game yesterday and and those are two
teams that I think have a lot of
likeable people two organizations that
have a lot of respect so it was one of
those things where that I didn't see a
villain in the game sometimes is a
villain in the Super Bowl that wasn't
the case yesterday in terms of the 49ers
to which you know I guess we should turn
our attention to there was they were up
by ten with six men 14 to go technically
hello as we know the Chiefs were
knocking on the door and scored a second
later to start this comeback
um you know good people there - John
Lynch is as good as they come
you know obviously Kyle Shanahan you you
know the way this business works out I
don't need to tell you I mean we're
already gonna starting it well
twenty-eight to three in Atlanta now you
got that twenty to ten lead fourth
quarter here what do you think everybody
needs a narrative right it's like look
we live in a world right now we have to
fill a gazillion hours of airtime
we newspapers have to fill a lot of
newsprint the internet God knows I mean
we're all over the place there everybody
needs something and so now it's like
okay this is the monkey on his back but
look at Kyle's a heck of a coach he's 40
years old he's gonna have a great run
you know I've known his dad since he was
coaching here in Los Angeles with the
Raiders back in 88 89 and I remember
going out to a practice one day and
there's a eight-year-old kid running
around and it's it's Kyle's we go back a
long way I know sometimes you just have
to live with those things but I think of
him as a guy right now that took a team
along with John Lynch built a pretty
good team built a really good football
team and they've got a lot of great
parts there too
I I think before it's all said and done
that he'll win is Super Bowl you may
want a couple like his dad did there's
just this setup this setup to be very
very good down the line but I mean the
great thing about football and the great
thing about sports that we love when you
think about the 49ers
they were 18 inches away from what going
on the road and having to win three
games you call back didn't get to the
sizzle instead Greenlaw makes the tackle
at the half yard line they get a bye
week two home games that's how close we
come to hey the whole narrative is
different so right now that's gonna be
part of it and sooner or later you hope
to extricate yourself and I think they
will yeah I mean if you if you think
about what you just referred to in game
256 an incredible end to the NFL 100
playing season regular season is that
that one inch been on the other side of
the goal line mm-hmm then Green Bay
would add home field throughout right
the Saints would add that second buy
week correct the Seahawks would have
been home for a three seed against the
Viking against the Viking and the if
they would have got to Philadelphia in
Philadelphia Philadelphia and then
probably Green Bay and then and then who
the heck knows I mean it could have
still been in the Super Bowl
but the Saints definitely wouldn't have
had their hands full with the Minnesota
Vikings the very next week right they
wouldn't have been just a third team to
have won as many games they did in the
regular season and not had a bye in the
current playoff format I mean it really
is so why don't we love sports rising I
know and the 49ers again a 4-1 team one
year there in the they got a ten-point
lead in the fourth quarter the next year
of a Super Bowl mm-hmm
you never know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I get goosebumps and chills and what I
just want to start crying every single
time I hear that al michaels another
segment with us live on the Rich Eisen
show right here forty years ago coming
up on February 22nd this month now and
this get a plug in from Mike Eruzione
who just wrote a book I just got it
yesterday recounting his life and his
career and then what happened and I
talked to Mike a lot we're gonna go all
that the whole team has been invited to
Las Vegas on that day February 22nd and
the nights the Golden Knights hockey you
know the NHL team yep
they have a game that night and they
want to honor the team so they're
bringing everybody in and I'm kind of
like the mascot of the team know I'll be
in there too and you know I talked to
Mike a lot it's gonna be that's really
gonna be a lot of fun but i mean ii
think that it's 40 years is it's crazy
rich totally yeah cuz i what do you
think of when you hear that i just wait
you saw the reaction of all three of us
here like we literally sat up in our
chairs and just i get emotional
what do you look i've heard thousands of
times back and thank god look thank god
some of the right words came out god
knows what I could have might have said
and so but it's very funny I've heard so
much and obviously I know it's what's
what's happening when the tape starts to
roll it's almost in a way I'm looking at
that or hearing that in the third person
it's like I know it's me obviously but I
think of it it's like I'm hearing it and
somebody else is doing it because I want
to enjoy the moment the way America
enjoyed the moment so I want I take
myself out of me out of my body put
myself in the third person I know it's
coming I know I know the great thing is
I know what it means to there's so many
people that happen at that particular
time a lot of people obviously have not
did not live through it we have to be at
least about 45 48 years old
member yeah yeah and then you'd be a
silly to be a child but one of the great
things too is that movie miracle that
was terrific and even though there's
some literary license taken it in that
movie it's not a documentary I mean HBO
did a fantastic documentary that came
out back in 2000 that was the real real
deal story you know right to the enth
degree but the movie captured the
essence of what took place and I mean
even to this day I talked to a lot of
you know kids coaches who will play the
movie the night before the game
and it will inspire the kids it put the
story in in perspective and even to this
day it's Chris Collinsworth but I can't
is that really Chris I'll call you right
back
Aloha that's priceless mom that is a
priceless moment but anyway the that
whole the whole story is so good and
I've said this many times in you and I
have talked about it there are so many
things you remember where you were and
none of them are very good I mean most
recently Kobe right people a lot of
people will always remember what when
they heard that 9/11 the Challenger goes
I mean all of these horrible things
people remember where they were if
you're of a certain age and and they
smile and it's an exultant moment
instead of a depressing moment and it's
still you know it's wonderful to talk
about it people said you ever get tired
of people talking to you about it no you
kidding me it's great people love it and
and here we go 40 years later rich crazy
then we talk about coaching all the time
obviously and II read today the 21 year
long slog for him to finally reach that
mountaintop and two more coaches getting
in in the hall and Cour and Jimmie
Johnson
what was her Brooks like cuz he
unfortunately will not be in Vegas with
you and the rest of the team on February
22nd to celebrate the 40th anniversary
what was what was her Brooks really like
curved
car accident I guess 12 or 15 years ago
he was through and through a hockey
coach is what he was and I mean just to
think about what he did after the
Olympics he coaches his team they pulled
off what Sports Illustrated ranked as
the greatest sports moment of the 20th
century at least in terms of the United
States sports what did he do
I mean here's a guy who could have gone
around the country been honored and
celebrated and parades you name it he
was he could have been the king of
America two weeks later what is he doing
he's in Davos Switzerland coaching a
Swiss club team because Herb Brooks was
a hockey coach and when we were all
gathered at Madison Square Garden in the
Sports Illustrated in conjunction with
CBS put on a at the at the end of the
century affair at Madison Square Garden
and they ranked it as the top moment of
the 20th century the sports and herb and
I and they had me introduced the team
and we're walking down off the stage
down a little
staircase and I'm walking next to herb
and he said how could they vote that the
number one moment and I said herb how
could they not vote this number one
moment would you stop it so he was
whatever took place around it Massey
wasn't interested in it but he had it
was it was moving on he got that team in
a position where they were able to pull
off what they did you know I mean Mike
details it in great measure in his book
or rosy on his book but he was I liked
him a lot and he was he kept you know at
a time forty years ago he kept the press
at bay and the only reason that I had
access to him was my partner was Ken
Dryden who had just retired as the
goalie for the Montreal Canadiens Hall
of Famer one of the greatest goalies of
all time and herb had a great respect
and admiration for Kenny so on every off
night which was every other night herb
would come over to our hotel we'd have a
beer and I had tremendous access to him
because of
Dryden and part of it too was he was he
was picking Ken's brain as well he knew
that ken was so smart understood every
aspect of hockey so he was a guy who he
was a taskmaster and remember don't
forget when when they won he disappeared
he went in the back and you know the
movie has him you know
crying he might have been doing that in
the hall but he did he wanted it was it
was their moment it was a team miss
moment and he had he didn't want he
didn't want to have any I don't wanna
see anyone ever any part of it but it
was just not it was not his deal to to
be out there and to be celebrated and to
be honored and all of the rest he was a
hockey coach how Michaels here on the
Rich Eisen show we asked you before
because the play from last night's game
was from the 1948 Rose Bowl I asked you
if you recall - Rose Bowl and you said
you did it on the radio I did which
which Rose Bowl was that well it was
1976 it was the Ohio State UCLA game
right Dick Vermeil upsets Woody Hayes
Frank and Wally Henry scores a touchdown
maybe I can't remember okay thanks two
touchdowns he scored it's as Chris is
saying over there sorry state was
undefeated in ranked number one right
and got taken out by UCLA Vermeil
deserves to be in the Hall I mean I I've
read so many deserving people to be in
the Hall but I mean Dick Vermeil has
been everywhere in football I mean you
want to talk about guy and because it
was just what a couple years later he's
in the Superbowl coaching this
Philadelphia Eagles right against
another guy who should be in the Hall
and Tom Flores right I mean there's so
many different ways to Sunday we can do
this sort of thing so back then you're
you're doing radio for Rose Bowl and
then doing some over the San Fran's
right and the the the radio rights
rolled by Golden West broadcasters which
included the station I worked for in San
Francisco KS fo and Campisi down here
right so I wound up being asked to do
the game on local radio because Fred
Hessler was their local announcer and he
was gonna do it on national radio and
then Kurt Goudy actually did the game on
television right and so I come down
there it was a one-off for me but it was
a great game and it were you doing Wide
World of Sports at the time no I had
just that was a year
for I left to to go to ABC full-time so
it was I think what I did is that year
that Monday night baseball started at
ABC and I was hired to do the B game
yeah
with norm cash and Bob Gibson so I did
that year I did the San Francisco Giants
right six days a week and Monday Night
Football on the seventh day so now the
the Monday Night Baseball a-team was
Keith Jackson and Howard Cosell was that
the month that was in 77 Keith Howard
euchre was there too I had well 76 no
was no 76 was Bob Prince who lasted less
than a year was Warner wolf on that I
came to know it was Bob Prince it was
Bob Uecker great might have been yep I
got Warner in the playoffs it was like
crazy you know let's go to the videotape
and get the whole thing give me your
best Yorker story you must have enough
oh of course I do
so a snooker story yeah and there are
4,000 so Uecker and Cosell and I are
doing a game in I think was Houston okay
and Howard you know the way Howard was
he was baseball such a simple game they
make it so complicated so it's a
situation late in the game where Howard
is going for a but now when somebody
calls for a bunt in a situation where
you can't but you know they know nothing
about baseball
so you cannot you know now Howard would
be spewing all this misinformation and
that yuccas trying to you know explain
the Howard carefully you know why you
probably wouldn't bunt in this situation
so it's a little bit he's chiding him
minimally and Cosell says on the
heiress's okay you ki you know you don't
have to be so truculent you do know what
truculent means don't you and where that
hesitating euchre says of course Howard
if you had a truck and I borrowed it
would be a truculent
and that is that is Bob Uecker without
skipper duty without skipping a beat and
the other thing with euchre is were
doing a game it's just the two of us to
do in a game later that season and
Charlie Finley owns the A's and he wants
to introduce the alert orange baseballs
because like the tennis balls soon as
you can see them so we start talking
about the game is terrible and we're
going back and forth and the U key
finally says look the bottom line is
this could never happen I go why not he
said you couldn't find enough disease
horses so brain how does the brain work
like I don't know why it showed up in my
Twitter timeline the other day but the
the Miller Lite commercial where he was
mr. baseball I must be in the front row
right like that's as they tell him he's
got a move and then they cut to him
three roads in the top of the stadium
screaming he missed the tag it it made
me laugh as much two days ago as it did
40 years rich there were two guys almost
everything that came out of their mouths
was hysterical hmm euchre and Don
Rickles and I knew both of them very
well and I mean I missed on so much and
and Yukie still the same I'll see you
key once in a while will go down for a
football game in Arizona and he's down
there in the offseason Andy he's got an
amazing brain he really does where did
you meet Rickles when did you first come
Rickles so I loved Don Rickles I saw him
when I was 18 years old and he brought
me up on stage and I played an Indian
chief come on
oh yeah when he was working in Vegas and
he was working a lounge and then years
later I got to meet him and he was at a
party and I saw him and I know I
idolized him I loved him
and he seized me from across the room
and I think it's a case of mistaken
identity and he comes up to me and he
goes I love you I said what you know no
no I love you I said Don I'm not sure he
knows it's me I don't know what he
thinks but I go Don you might love me
but I love you 10 times more than you
can ever love me
mm-hmm so then he said we're back and
forth and he says hey listen he says the
next time you're out here you think
we're gonna have dinner he assumes I
live in in New York I said Don I live in
Brentwood I said can we have dinner like
every other night for the rest of our
lives
I said where do you live egos a little
in Spain I just came in for the party
and then the Donnie barber and my wife
Linda and I and we had we'd have dinner
with them a lot a lot and I miss him so
much cuz he's a big sports fan he was he
was a huge he used to go home at night
mm-hm and watch the Dodger replay until
four o'clock in the morning really you
know Don's whole life was basically to
work in the Vegas and work in shows and
being up all night right so he would go
home on a night when he'd be you know
home at midnight right he would tell me
he would lie in bed and watch the Dodger
replay till 4:00 in the morning now he
loves sports he loves sports
he was - was he he was tight with
Lasorda right very titled was shorter
right and of course the Frank Sinatra
stories are are classic and then one
night I remember so I was playing golf
with Don with Doc Rivers who was my
broadcast partner back in the early
2000s and I told doc I was having dinner
with Don Rickles and Doc so I love I
love Don you know someday maybe I like
to go to dinner so I went home and I
called Don I said hey that was a big
sports fan you know would you mind if I
invited Doc Rivers to dinner mm-hmm oh
that's great so we show up or at mr.
Chow's it's Linden me and Barbara and
Don and Doc's a little bit late doc
walks up to the table and I said this is
Doc Rivers and Don doesn't even look at
me looks at me and he goes who invited
him for three hours I mean it's just II
you ache your stomach just aches when
you leave because you're just laughing
so hard man
well Mike is there al Michaels few more
minutes left with with uh with you here
on the show I've never asked you this on
air off the air I'll ask you here is
there anything you want to call that if
you had a choice you know what I've
never called this event but I'd I would
do it what would that be you know rich
there is nothing because I've been
blessed you know Superbowl and World
Series and NBA Finals and you know
hosted the Stanley Cup Finals and the
Olympics and Hagler Hearns abut it's
crazy societies
said to me once what about the World Cup
soccer yeah and I said well I've never
been to a soccer game I don't think I
would historically announcing that's not
gonna happen you ever been to a soccer
game I've never been to a soccer game
I've been to my when my son was sake was
ten years old
no but I've never been to a to a soccer
game
so what else I mean look I'm the guy
who's done motorcycles on ice in Germany
right what there's a there's was an
event on wide world with sports it was a
stable four years we'd go over to Enzo
West Germany at the little town of Aryan
Alps between Munich and Salzburg Austria
and these guys would would ride
motorcycles with spikes protruding that
honor on a speed skating rink a
quarter-mile yeah and it was all Eastern
Europeans well czechoslovakians and and
the Soviets and the poles yeah and that
was a that was one of my first-ever
assignments at Wide World of Sports how
do you call something like that and
they're coming around the end you know
you making it up who knows who anybody
is right but it was just the wildness of
you see that's what Wide World of Sports
was it brought you to places you
couldn't go and it seems so ridiculous
right now but remember that was the the
days of satellite television yeah so
wide world would take you to places
you've never been before
boxing in Moscow boxing in Cuba I was in
Cuba in 1983 calling the US against
against the Cubans in amateur boxing in
every other year Fidel Castro would show
up and you had to be ready to interview
him he did not show up the year that I
did it right but you would be able to go
to places that you couldn't get to and
certainly on television that was the
advent of satellite technology soup wide
world took you truly right around the
world yeah I don't know if you saw the
movie Ford versus Ferrari I don't know
if you saw that but that was I met the
writer the other night that's so funny
yeah I haven't seen about a new Carroll
Shelby I've got to see that movie I have
to it really is very well done and
there's a lot of you know I mean ABC
Sports was there
sure you know I'm sure there's a
probably a great Roone Arledge story
behind that sort of thing oh yeah oh
yeah what would he think of today's
television industry do you think he
would have evolved I mean he ruined was
a master he figured room was remember
he's the guy that created up close and
personal and ruler Siri was and he hired
me at ABC and he was my boss for 10
years the first and he went to news only
his his feeling was look the games
there's a similarity to the games but
what makes each game distinct very
people and the personalities so
especially in the Olympics and the
Olympics what he was able to do was make
gymnastics and figure skating and some
of the other sports that are not
secondary sports but not baseball in
football and basketball make them more
relevant I mean he really created that
it's this whole gymnastics genre because
he had not a common each and Nadiya
companies Olga Korbut and all of those
people from from that era and he made
them he made them people you make you
understood their backstories and that
was what it was all about in those years
it was who are these people and why
shouldn't I be interested in them and
who do I root for who do i root against
and so look we all who grew up under
roon in a way learned a lot from Roone
Arledge and I mean to this day a lot of
what he put in place is still around
there's no doubt about it I mean
Olympics and you calling 10 Super Bowls
as you have and Sunday Night Football
and Monday Night Football I mean those
are those are the premium events you
want to call as a broadcaster and then
they still are right now yeah I'm
television you know he was look I mean
he was one of the iconic figures not
only in television but I mean just the
way he it went beyond television like I
say he he's the guy that you know kind
of brought you to places you couldn't go
before right I mean it sounds a little
so ridiculous right now when you know
and get on a phone right here and talk
to somebody like Collins were you know a
college area in those years it was so
different you're the man now either man
and so you have Super Bowl two years
right up the road here right that's yeah
he met you at the mic correct for that
one probably you know walk home
with the traffic you might have to you
might be ought to hit the scanner during
halftime long enough those the
intermissions man love ya hey look back
at any time in that sound Michaels right
here on the Rich Eisen show
you